la incertidumbre reina en las fronteras
sureñas de Estados Unidos la razón el
fin del título 42 la normativa creada en
la era de Donald Trump que permitió
realizar unas 2.6 millones de
expulsiones de migrantes durante la
emergencia del covid 19 para muchos
luego de la medianoche del 11 de mayo
habrá un relajamiento en las medidas
pero Estados Unidos ha sido claro
nuestras fronteras no están abiertas las
personas que crucen nuestra frontera
ilegalmente y sin una base legal para
permanecer serán procesadas y expulsadas
de inmediato
el título 42 será reemplazado por el
título 8 aquellos que quieran solicitar
asilo lo deben hacer A través de una
aplicación desde sus países de origen Si
llegan a Estados Unidos sin haber
cumplido con el requisito serán
deportados y vetados durante al menos
cinco años si los descubren reincidiendo
se exponen a penas de prisión
para descongestionar las fronteras
Estados Unidos implementará centros
regionales de procesamiento en distintos
países inicialmente en Colombia y
Guatemala el título 8 entró en vigor por
primera vez en 1940 y ahora con su
retoma se espera una alteración del
orden público por lo que Estados Unidos
anunció un gran despliegue de fuerza
militar y México ofreció su ayuda
nosotros
ayudando en el sureste para que
se proteja a migrantes instrucción de
no utilizar
la fuerza del desarrollo del título ocho
puede depender la fuerza que tenga Joe
biden para su reelección en 2024 la
frontera se ha convertido en uno de los
temas que más preocupa a los
estadounidenses